>>> YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE
"GROUP CHAT" LIVE IN THE
"BLEACHER REPORT" PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL.
I'M GREG IVORY ALONG WITH LIV.
WE HAVE BUCKS/SUNS TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST LET'S TALK TRADES.
LIV, LOTS OF TRADE ACTION THE
LAST FEW HOURS.
THE 76ers TRADED FOR BEN
SIMMONS, SETH CURRY, ANDRE
DRUMMOND AND TWO FIRST-ROUND
PICKS TO THE BROOKLYN NETS FOR
JAMES HARDEN AND PAUL MILSAP.
PORZINGIS IS HEADING TO
WASHINGTON.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT HOW
THESE TRADES AFFECT FUTURES
MARKETS IN JUST A MINUTE.
LIF
LIV, GIVE US YOUR IMMEDIATE
REACTIONS.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, MY IMMEDIATE REACTION
OFF THE BAT IS I'M NOT SURE IF
JAMES HARDEN IS WORTH BEN
SIMMONS, SETH CURRY, DROM MUMMO
AND DRAFT PICKS.
THAT'S A LOT.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE HOW THIS
SIMMONS SITUATION PLAYS OUT IN
THE NETS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE'S BEEN
SPENDING HIS OFF-TIME.
HOPEFULLY HE'S BEEN IN THE GYM
WORKING ON HIS SHOT AND FINDING
THAT AGGRESSION.
HE'S JOINING A TEAM IN THE NETS
THAT IS PRETTY AGGRESSIVE AND
COMPETITIVE.
HOPEFULLY IT'S A GOOD FIT OVER
THERE.
FINALLY MY THOUGHT IS I CANNOT
WAIT TO WATCH HARDEN AND EMBIID.
THAT'S A DYNAMIC DUO.
THEY PLAY A SIMILAR STYLE
BASKETBALL, JUST THAT HUSTLE,
THAT LEADERSHIP THEY HAVE
WITH -- I'M NOT JUST GOING TO
TELL YOU WHAT TO DO, I'LL SHOW
YOU HOW TO DO IT.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE WHAT THEY DO.
IT WILL BE EXCITING STUFF.
TRADES ALWAYS EXCITE ME, BUT IT
WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE HOW
IT PLAYS OUT.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS IN THE AIR,
BUT THOSE QUESTIONS WILL BE
ANSWERED IN THE SECOND HALF OF
THIS NBA SEASON.
WE HAVE SOME TRADES OF OUR OWN
HERE, LIV.
TO MAKE AROUND HERE.
YOU GIVE US COMMENTS, WE'LL GIVE
YOU HOODIES, JERSEYS, LOCKS.
WE NEED GIFS.
WE NEED EMOJIS, MOST IMPORTANTLY
WE NEED --
>> WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
>> WE'RE STILL GETTING THERE,
LIV.
WE PRACTICED IT.
WE'RE STILL GETTING THERE.
THAT'S OKAY.
I'M GOING TO ACCEPT THAT.
RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY
A JERSEY.
I'M IN THE "BLEACHER REPORT" APP
LOOKING UP THE COMMENTS.
I SEE MAXEL IN HERE.
HE SAYS OVER TONIGHT FOR
GIANNIS.
I ALSO SEE JAY LOPEZ 9.
HE SAYS HONESTLY, BRO, THEY'VE
BEEN DOMINATING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
I WANTED TO GIVE HIM A HOODIE.
WHY NOT?
OH, HE'S HAVING A CONVERSATION
WITHIN THE COMMENTS.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING DOWN.
TWO PEOPLE HAVING A CONVERSATION
WITHIN THE COMMENTS.
THEREFORE, I'LL GIVE YOU A
HOODIE.
I'LL GIVE YOU A JERSEY.
YOU'RE FILLING UP OUR COMMENTS,
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITHIN OUR
COMMENTS.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE -- ACTUALLY, A JERSEY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW THE
HARDEN/SIMMONS TRADE AFFECTS THE
FUTURES.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS TO WIN
THE EAST.
DO YOU THINK PHILLY SHOULD BE
FAVORED OVER THE NETS NOW?
>> YEAH, I PERSONALLY THINK SO.
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE NETS
BIGGEST DOWNFALLS THIS SEASON
HAS BEEN THEIR CHEMISTRY OR LACK
THE
THEREOF.
YOU HAVE K.D. BATTLING INJURIES.
IT SEEMS JAMES HARDEN IS THE
ONLY CONSISTENT PERSON ON THE
COURT THROUGHOUT THE SEASON AND
HE'S LEAVING.
KYRIE CAN'T PLAY IN EVERY GAME
HE'S IN.
THE CHEMISTRY HAS BEEN THE
BIGGEST STRUGGLE, I'M NOT SURE
BEN SIMMONS, SETH CURRY OR
DRUMMOND WILL BE ABLE TO FIX
THAT.
I THINK JAMES HARDEN, BEING THE
MOST CONSISTENT PLAYER ON THIS
NETS TEAM IS GONE.
I'M INTERESTED TO SEE HOW THIS
CHEMISTRY WORKS.
I'M NOT SOLD ON THEM.
I'M NOT.
I WORRY ABOUT THE CHEMISTRY FOR
THEM.
THE 76ers, THEY ALREADY GOT THAT
ESTABLISHED CHEMISTRY.
THEY'RE WINNING GAMES.
AND EMBIID JUST NEEDS A BUDDY.
HE NEEDS A BUDDY TO HELP HIM
WIN.
THAT'S GOING TO BE JAMES HARDEN.
I LIKE THE 76ers A LOT BETTER IN
THIS TRADE SPOT THAN THE NETS.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO PUT MORE
RESPECT ON THIS BUCKS TEAM IN
THE EAST.
THEY'RE A TEAM THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED WITH THAT CHEMISTRY.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF STRONG
PLAYERS, DEEP ROSTERS.
IT MAKES ME WONDER IF THE BUCKS
ARE SITTING IN A NICE SPOT WITH
ALL THESE DIFFERENT THINGS
CHANGING FOR THESE TWO TEAMS.
THE BUCKS MIGHT BE IN A GOOD
POSITION HERE.
>> LIV IS SAYING PUT SOME
RESPECT ON THOSE MILWAUKEE
BUCKS.
BUT NOW LET'S TALK CHAMPIONSHIP.
LET'S TALK CHAMPIONSHIP.
ARE YOU THINKING ANYTHING
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT FINALS
FUTURES?
>> LIKE I SAID, THE BUCKS, THERE
CAN BE MORE RESPECT FOR THEM
COMING OUT OF THE EAST.
IN TERMS OF THE EAST, YEAH,
BESIDES THE BUCKS, I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY CONCERNS.
THE WEST, I THINK, STAYS THE
SAME.
YOU HAVE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS
TEAM THAT ONCE HEALTHY WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WHERE THEY WERE WHEN
DRAYMOND WAS ON THE COURT.
THE SUNS ARE OBVIOUSLY PLAYING
WELL.
IT AFFECTS THE EAST THE MOST.
I STILL FEEL GOOD ABOUT WHERE
THE WEST IS SITTING.
JUST MORE RESPECT FOR THE BUCKS
AND WE'LL RIDE WITH THE
WARRIORS.
>> I LIKE WHAT YOU SAID THERE,
RIDE WITH THE WARRIORS.
THAT'S WHERE I'M BETTING.
THAT'S DEFINITELY WHERE I'M
BETTING.
ALSO, I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT THE
PHILADELPHIA 76ers PLUS 1100.
THEY JUST GOT JAMES HARDEN, THEY
HAVE JOEL EMBIID, THEY HAVE DOC
RIVERS.
THEY HAVE PIECES.
THEY HAVE PIECES TO AT LEAST GET
TO THE FINALS AND THEN POSSIBLY
PLAY IN THE SEVEN-GAME MATCH-UP
TO WIN IT.
SITTING AT PLUS 1100.
NOT BAD TO SPRINKLE SOME MONEY
ON THAT.
LIV, I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, I GOT THE
HANDY DANDY PHONE TODAY.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES NOW FOR TAKES.
I HAVE M. BOLLIN IN THE
COMMENTS, EMBIID IS THE G.O.A.T.
SHOUT OUT TO JOEL EMBIID FOR THE
MEME HE SENT OUT TODAY.
C.J. SAYS DON'T SLEEP ON HIS
HEAT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, C.J., YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I ALSO GOT SNOOPY 2153, HE SAYS
THE WARRIORS ARE NOT BAD VALUE
RIGHT NOW.
I AGREE.
COLIN FROST SAYS DOC RIVERS IS
AN AWFUL COACH.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
BROTHER, THOSE ARE BAD VIBES.
YOU DEFINITELY HAVE AN OPINION.
THOSE ARE BAD VIBES.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO HERE?
WE TURN BAD VIBES INTO GOOD
VIBES.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, IT'S TNT BASKETBALL
THURSDAY.
WHICH MEANS WE ARE BETTING THE
3x2.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
TODAY WE ARE RUNNING IT BACK.
THE 3x2 PARLAY.
WE GOT THE BROOKLYN NETS TAKING
ON THE WASHINGTON WIZARDS AND
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS TAKING ON
THE PHOENIX SUNS.
IT'S BOOSTED, LIV, FROM LUPLUS 0
TO PLUS 450.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THERE BE
TWO OR MORE THREE-POINTERS MADE
IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES OF
EACH OF THESE GAMES?
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
IF YOU'RE RIDING WITH US.
LIV, TALK TO THE PEOPLE, WHAT
ARE YOU THINKING?
>> GRAB YOUR SWEAT TOWELS, THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE AN EASY ONE.
WE'LL BE SWEATING.
WE'LL BE SWEATING IT OUT.
BUT NO GOOD CASH OUT DOESN'T
COME WITHOUT A LITTLE SWEAT.
JUST GET USED TO IT.
BUT, IT'S DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
A SWEAT.
THIS WASHINGTON -- IT'S
WASHINGTON, IT'S THE NETS, IT'S
ALSO THE SUNS THAT RANK BOTTOM
TEN IN THREE-POINTERS MADE.
THAT MAKES ME A LITTLE BIT MER
VOU
NERVOUS.
HOWEVER, THIS BUCKS TEAM RANKS
TOP FIVE IN BOTH THREES
ATTEMPTED AND MADE.
SO WE ARE PUTTING A LOT OF FAITH
IN THIS BUCKS TEAM AND PUTTING A
LOT OF FAITH IN A GUY NAMED
KYRIE IRVING.
I THINK KYRIE IS MAKING A
STATEMENT TONIGHT.
HE IS, YOU KNOW, WITHOUT HARDEN
AND WITHOUT K.D., HE'S TRYING TO
SHOW THIS NETS TEAM WILL BE JUST
FINE.
WE'LL BE JUST FINE.
THAT'S THE VIBE I THINK HE'S
GOING TO PLAY WITH TONIGHT.
WE ARE PUTTING ALL OF OUR
ENERGY, TIME, AND STRESS INTO
KYRIE IRVING AND THE BUCKS IN
ORDER TO GET IT DONE.
IT WILL BE A SWEAT.
JUST GET PREPARED.
>> LIV IS KEEPING IT A BUCK WITH
EVERYBODY SAYING IT WILL BE A
SWEAT.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY RIDING AND
PUTTING OUR FAITH IN THE BUCKS
AND KYRIE IRVING.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
SEEING WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
I GOT THIS ONE, HE GAVE US A
GIF, IT SAYS I BELIEVE IN THIS
TEAM.
HE'S BELIEVING IN US, RIDING
WITH US.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
JS23 SAYS YOU CAN TRUST THE
NETS.
HE'S TALKING TO YOU SAYING YOU
CAN TRUST THE NETS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE RIDING -- WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
WE ARE ALL RIDING THE 3x2 PA
Y
PARLAY.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
Y'ALL WALKING AWAY WITH HOODIES.
TODAY IN THE APP WE ASKED YOU
HOW MANY POINTS GIANNIS IS GOING
TO SCORE?
THE LINE IS CURRENTLY SET AT
29.5.
LET'S LOOK AT SOME OTHER PLAYER
POINT PROPS.
LIV, DO YOU THINK GIANNIS WILL
HAVE OVER OR UNDER 29.5 POINTS?
ARE THERE ANY OTHER PROPS YOU
LIKE ON THE BOARD?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, I DON'T WORRY ABOUT
GIANNIS SCORING OVER 29.5 POINTS
UP AGAINST THIS SUNS TEAM.
RIGHT NOW THEY GIVE UP -- IN THE
LAST SEVEN THEY HAVE GIVEN UP 24
POINTS A GAME AGAINST OPPOSING
POWER FORWARDS, GIANNIS IS NOT
YOUR AVERAGE POWER FORWARD I
THINK HE'LL PLAY WELL TONIGHT.
I GOT TO RUN IT BACK.
LAST WEEK I TOLD YOU ABOUT MIKAL
BRIDGES, HE HAD HIMSELF A GAME.
I LIKE HIM IN THIS SPOT AGAIN
TONIGHT.
HE IS FACING A BUCKS TEAM THAT
IN THE LAST SEVEN HAS ALLOWED
THE FIFTH MOST POINTS TO
OPPOSING SMALL FORWARDS AT
ALMOST 25 PER GAME.
HIS LINE IS AT 14.5 RIGHT NOW.
HE HIT THAT OVER IN FOUR OF THE
LAST FIVE.
I LIKE THIS SPOT FOR MIKAL AGAIN
TONIGHT.
WE CASHED ON HIM LAST WEEK,
WE'LL KEEP IT MOVING.
I WON'T FADE ON HIM UNTIL I HAVE
TO.
I LOVE HIM FACING THIS BUCKS
TEAM TONIGHT.
GIVE ME MIKAL BRIDGES, OVER 14.5
POINTS.
>> LIV IS RUNNING IT BACK.
MY MOM ALWAYS SAID IF IT'S NOT
BROKE, DON'T FIX IT.
HIT LAST WEEK.
LIV IS RUNNING IT BACK WITH
MIKAL BRIDGES AGAIN.
I LIKE THAT PICK.
I KIND OF LIKE IT MORE THAN MY
PLAY, I'LL TELL YOU WHAT I'M
ROCKING WITH.
I'M ROCKING WITH DEVIN BOOKER
OVER -- I THINK THIS ONE WILL
HIT.
MY MAN HAS BEEN ON FIRE.
THE LAST TIME I ROCKED WITH A D.
BOOK OVER, HE LAID 11 POINTS FOR
ME.
HOPEFULLY THE VIBES ARE CHANGED.
HOPEFULLY THE ATMOSPHERE IS
GOING TO GIVE US SOME GOOD
VIBES, SOME GOOD JUJU SO WE CAN
GET THIS DEVIN BOOKER OVER
TONIGHT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
I SEE BR BETTING IN THE
COMMENTS.
SHOUT OUT TO BR BETTING.
I SEE OFFICIAL RONALD, GO WITH
ALL THE SUNS PLAYERS.
I GUESS HE'S SAYING GO WITH ALL
THE SUNS PLAYERS OVER?
I'M GUESSING.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
OFFICIALLY RONALD YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
PARTIALLY PERKINS HAS A SUNSET
GIF.
THERE IT IS.
SUNSET GIF.
SUNSETS ARE THE WAY TO MY HEART.
NOT GOING TO LIE.
PARLAY PERKINS, YOU KNOW --
YOU'VE BEEN A FAN FOR A WHILE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS
MONEY LINES AGAINST THE SPREADS
AND POINT TOTALS FOR TONIGHT'S
GAME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING HERE AND
WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> I HAVE TO FADE THE NETS
TONIGHT.
I'M LIKING THE WIZARDS AT HOME,
MINUS 1.5 TO COVER THAT SPREAD.
THIS NETS TEAM STRUGGLED WITHOUT
K.D.
THEY GOT A LACK OF CONSISTENCY
RIGHT NOW.
KYRIE IRVING WILL BE PLAYING
TONIGHT.
I IMAGINE HE'LL HAVE A BIG
NIGHT, HOWEVER HE CAN'T DO IT
ALONE.
PATTY MILLS IS A LITTLE TOO
INCONSISTENT FOR MY LIKING.
I DON'T TRUST THE NETS IN THIS
SPOT.
THEY STRUGGLED WITHOUT K.D.
K.D. IS NOT BACK.
NOW THEY HAVE NO HARDEN AS WELL.
THE WIZARDS ARE IN A BETTER SPOT
TO GET A DUB AT HOME.
GIVE ME THE WIZARDS MINUS 1.5.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH THE
WIZARDS.
I LIKE THAT ONE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
MILWAUKEE BUCKS/PHOENIX SUNS
GAME.
I JUST -- THIS MILWAUKEE TEAM
HAS BEEN ON THE HOT STREET ON
THE WEST COAST.
I LIKE THE MONEY LINE.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
PEOPLE WANT HOODIES, THEY WANT
TO GET THEIR VOICE HEARD.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
COLIN FROST IS BACK IN THE
COMMENTS.
HE SAID NEXT LOSING STREAK ENDS
TONIGHT.
TRIGGER WAY IS RIGHT ABOVE HIM
WITH THE GIF OF KYRIE IRVING.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HE ALSO TOLD YOU -- I THINK HE
SAID -- SORRY.
HE SAID THAT THE NETS WILL WIN,
THAT'S FADING YOU, BUT THAT'S
OKAY.
WE KNOW WHAT YOU DO TO BAD VIBES
HERE.
WE GIVE THEM GOOD VIBES.
THE DUCK IS A GREEN WITH ME.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I HAVE ANOTHER TAKE.
LARRY SAYS NETS MONEY LINE
BECAUSE THE PLAYERS INVOLVED IN
THE TRADES WON'T PLAY TONIGHT
FOR THE WIZARDS.
THE COMMENTS ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT
COMMENTED.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
WE TALKED MAJOR MARKETS.
NOW LET'S TALK PLAYER PROPS.
IT'S TIME FOR LOCK OR NOT.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHETHER IT
IS A LOCK OR IT'S NOT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST UP SHGIS KYRIE IRVING TO
SCORE 30 OR MORE POINTS.
SITTING AT PLUS 150.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> I LIKE IT.
I THINK IT'S A LOCK.
HE'S KIND OF -- HE'S GOT TO BE
THE MAIN GUY TONIGHT FOR THIS
NETS TEAM FOR EVERYONE IN THE
CHAT FADING ME, NO BEEF, BUT WE
CAN AGREE ON THIS ONE, IF YOU
THINK THE NETS ARE WINNING THAT
KYRIE IRVING HAS TO HAVE A BIG
GAME.
IT'S BETWEEN HIM AND MILLS.
LIKE I SAID, A LITTLE TOO MUCH
INCONSISTENCY WITH MILLS FOR ME.
NOT TO MENTION KYRIE IRVING
WITHOUT K.D. IS AVERAGING 25
POINTS PER GAME THIS SEASON.
WITHOUT HARDEN AVERAGING 24.
30 PLUS, WHAT'S FIVE OR SIX MORE
POINTS?
HE CAN DO IT.
>> LIV -- LIV IS ROCKING WITH
KYRIE IRVING.
I'M GOING TO HOP IN RIGHT NOW.
LIV, I'M RIGHT THERE -- NO, I'M
NOT.
I'M NOT THERE WITH YOU.
I DON'T THINK KYRIE WILL GET TO
30.
IT'S PLUS 150 FOR A REASON.
I THINK I'LL LEAN THE OTHER WAY.
THERE'S JUST BEEN A LOT OF
INCONSISTENCIES GOING ON IN
BROOKLYN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE GOING TO
CHANGE TONIGHT.
I KNOW KYRIE NEEDS TO SCORE.
I KNOW THEY NEED TO WIN, I DON'T
THINK HE'LL DROP 30 TONIGHT.
LET'S MOVE ON.
WE GOT MILLS TO HAVE FOUR OR
MORE THREE-POINTERS MADE AT PLUS
154.
TALK TO ME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> I DON'T.
LIKE I SAID, TOO MUCH
INCONSISTENCY HERE WITH MILLS
FOR ME.
THIS WIZARDS TEAM GIVES UP THE
SECOND FEWEST THREE-POINTERS TO
THEIR OPPONENTS.
I MEAN, REALISTICALLY HE SHOULD
HIT THIS.
IT'S HIM AND KYRIE.
THAT'S ABOUT IT.
I DON'T TRUST HIM ENOUGH FOR
FOUR PLUS.
>> THAT'S A LOT OF THREES.
THAT'S STEPH CURRY TERRITORY.
I'M ONLY BETTING ON FOUR MORE
THREES UNLESS THE NAME IS STEPH
CURRY.
I'M COOL OFF OF THIS PATTY
MILLS.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS AND
SEE WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
I GOT M. KENT 93 SAYS UNDER ON
PATTY.
STEVE IRWIN SAYS UNDER ON PATTY
MILLS 3.
THIS ONE SAYS LIV, THAT CASHES
EASILY.
I THINK HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
FIRST ONE WITH THE OVER THAT YOU
TOOK.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU ARE ALL WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, FINALLY WE HAVE KYLE KUZMA.
8 OR MORE REBOUNDS SITTING AT
MINUS 166.
TALK TO ME, DO YOU LIKE THIS
ONE?
DO YOU NOT?
>> I DO.
SURPRISINGLY IN THE LAST SEVEN
THE NETS HAVE GIVEN UP THE THIRD
FEWEST REBOUNDS TO POWER
FORWARDS AT ALMOST EIGHT.
RIGHT WHERE WE NEED IT TO BE.
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT STORY TONIGHT WITH SO
MANY PEOPLE OUT, NO HARDEN.
KYRIE AND PATTY MILLS TO ME ARE
NOT HUGE REBOUNDERS.
I LIKE THIS SPOT FOR KUZMA.
I'LL ROCK WITH IT.
I THINK KUZMA CAN GET 8 PLUS.
I'LL SAY IT'S A LOCK.
HE'S BEEN REBOUNDING WELL.
I'LL LOCK WITH IT.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
I'M ROCKING WITH IT.
I THINK IT'S MINUS 166 FOR A
REASON.
THE BOOKIES -- THE CASINOS, THE
ODDSMAKERS KNOW WHAT'S UP.
I'M ROCKING WITH YOU AS WELL.
LET'S GO TO THE COMMENTS.
LET'S GO TO THE COMMENTS AND
LET'S SEE WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
I SEE BUCKS MONEY LINE, I. SILVA
SAYING THEY SEE THE BUCKS MONEY
LINE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
AND RUBIN XAMLOL, KUZMA IS A
LOCK.
ROCKING WITH YOU, LIV.
AND I HAVE ONE MORE.
THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
THEY ARE JUMPING.
LANI HALL, HE'S GOING OVER.
YEAH.
KYLE KUZMA IS GOING OVER.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
IT'S TIME TO BUILD THE CUSTOM
SAME-GAME PARLAY, WHICH YOU CAN
RIDE WITH US ON FAN DUEL.
WE HIT TWO SAME-GAME PARLAYS IN
A ROW.
LAST THURSDAY WE CASHED IN THE
SUN/HAWKS GAME.
IT PAID 5-1.
ON TUESDAY, WE HIT ANOTHER IN
THE LAKERS/BUCKS GAME.
ALMOST 15,000 PEOPLE RODE WITH
US.
TAKING A PAY DAY OF OVER 1.$1.1
MILLION.
TONIGHT WE'RE TRYING TO HIT
THREE IN A ROW.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE BUCKS/SUNS
GAME.
EVERYBODY GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK.
WHICH LEGS ARE LOCKS.
WHICH LEGS ARE NOT.
LIV
LIV, I'M READY TO GET TO IT.
ARE YOU READY?
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> FIRST OFF STARTING OFF WITH
THE POINT GOD HIMSELF, CHRIS
PAUL TO RECORD 12 OR MORE
ASSISTS.
TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A LOCK OR
NOT?
>> I LOVE IT.
I THINK THIS LEG IS GREAT.
HE'S FACING A BUCKS TEAM THAT
GIVES UP THE THIRD MOST ASSISTS
TO OPPOSING POINT GUARDS.
LOVE THIS SPOT FOR CHRIS PAUL.
I ALSO, IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY,
THE LAST TIME WE HAD A SAME-GAME
PARLAY, WE HAD CHRIS PAUL IN
THERE FOR 12 PLUS ASSISTS, IT
HIT.
IT HAS GRIT ENERGY EAT ENERGY B.
THIS LEG IS AWESOME.
>> LIV IS LOCKING IN THE FIRST
LEG OF THE PARLAY, CHRIS PAUL 12
PLUS ASSISTS.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE SECOND LEG
OF THE PARLAY.
DEVIN BOOKER TO SCORE 25 OR MORE
POINTS.
LIV, TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS LEG OF THE PA
PAR
PARLAY?
>> FOR THE SAKE OF YOUR BEST
BET, I'LL SAY ABSOLUTELY.
YOU'RE ON THE MONEY WITH DEVIN
BOOKER TONIGHT.
I THINK HE HAS HIMSELF A NIGHT.
HE IS FACING A BUCKS TEAM THAT
GIVES UP QUITE A FEW POINTS TO
OPPOSING SHOOTING GUARDS.
BOOKER IS THAT GUY.
IF THIS IS GOING TO BE A
COMPETITIVE GAME, IT WON'T BE AN
EASY WIN FOR THE SUNS BY ANY
MEANS.
BOOKER IS THE GUY YOU TRUST TO
GET POINTS ON THE BOARD AND KEEP
THEM IN THIS ONE.
I LIKE HIM TO HAVE A BIG
OFFENSIVE NIGHT AND KEEP DOING
WHAT HE'S BEEN DOING.
YEAH, 25 PLUS, I LIKE IT.
>> YES.
LIV LIKES ONE OF MY BETS I GAVE
YOU TODAY.
SO WE'RE MOVING ON.
WE'RE MOVING ON.
KHRIS MIDDLETON, TWO PLUS MADE
THREE-POINTERS TONIGHT.
LIV, DO YOU LIKE THIS LEG OF THE
PARLAY?
>> I DO.
KHRIS MIDDLETON HAS HIT THIS
OVER IN THE LAST FIVE
CONSECUTIVE MATCH-UPS.
LIKE I SAID, IT'S GOING TO BE A
TOUGH GAME FOR BOTH TEAMS.
THESE ARE TWO STRONG TEAMS THAT
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BALL HERE,
KHRIS MIDDLETON WILL BE TAKING A
LOT OF SHOTS FROM THE THREE TO
KEEP THE BUCKS IN THIS ONE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A COMPETITIVE
MATCH-UP.
I LIKE THIS ONE AS WELL.
>> LIV IS LIKING IT.
LIKING THIS ONE.
>> I AM.
>> LET'S MOVE TO THE LAST LEG OF
THE PARLAY.
MY MAN GIANNIS TO RECORD 10 OR
MORE REBOUNDS.
LIV, YOU LIKED EVERYTHING SO
FAR.
DO YOU LIKE THIS LAST LEG OF THE
PARLAY?
>> I DO.
ANY TIME YOU HAVE GIANNIS
GETTING BOARDS, IT'S A GOOD BET.
I KNOW THIS SUNS TEAM HAS HAD
THEIR BIG MAN WHO DOES A LOT OF
REBOUNDING, AYTON.
I THINK GIANNIS IS IN A GOOD
SPOT HERE TO GET SOME REBOUNDS.
HE SEEMS TO HIT IT PRETTY OFTEN.
IT DOESN'T SEEM -- I DON'T SEE
ANYONE ON THIS SUNS TEAM THAT
CAN GUARD GIANNIS TO THE POINT
WHERE HE WOULDN'T HIT.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY ON THE SUNS
TEAM THAT CAN GUARD GIANNIS
MYSELF.
LET'S PUT UP THE TICKET SO I CAN
SHOW YOU GUYS THE ODDS AND THE
TOTALS FOR THIS PARLAY.
THERE IT IS.
IF YOU PUT UP $100 YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH $400.35.
YES, THERE IT IS.
I'M GOING TO GRADE THIS PARLAY.
USUALLY I ASK LIV TO GRADE THE
PARLAY, BUT WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
DIFFERENT.
I'M GOING TO GRADE THE PARLAY.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT AN "A."
I'M THE ONE THAT TOLD YOU GUYS
ABOUT THE PARLAY.
WHY WOULDN'T I GIVE IT AN "A."
I HOPE WE HIT THIS PARLAY.
YOU GUYS CAN RIDE WITH US AT
FANDUEL.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW
GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND JERSEYS.
DALE PREET SAYS THIS IS EASY
MONEY.
APPRECIATE YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I SEE SPORTS BEAT, HE HAS A --
IT'S A LOCK.
HE'S UNLOCKING THE LOCK.
I THINK THIS IS GOOD VIBES
MEANING WE WILL WIN OUR BET.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I HAVE TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY.
I SEE XAVIER SAEZ WHO SAYS EASY
MONEY TO OUR PARLAY.
THEY ARE ROCKING WITH US.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
YOU ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
IT'S BEEN FUN.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
"GROUP CHAT."
IT'S BEEN FUN PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE 3x2 IS A LOCK.
GET ON FAN DUEL AND BR BETTING
SAME GAME PARLAY.
WE'RE TRYING TO HIT THREE IN A
ROW.
WE NEED GOOD VIBES.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT THURSDAY WITH
THE SPECIAL ALL-STAR GAME
PREVIEW GIVING OUT MORE HOODIES,
MORE JERSEYS AND MORE LOCKS.
IF YOU U
YOU WON A HOODIE TOD
WILL DM YOU.
ALONGSIDE LIV MOODS, I'M GREG
IVORY, I'M LEAVING THE GROUP
CHAT.
PEACE.
♪